(electronic music)
- That sounds like a deal we should take.
(knock on door)
- Hey, Jim?
- Oh, hey, Tyler, come on in.
I'm sorry, you'll have to excuse me,
my daughter's wonderful boyfriend has just
come in to surprise me.
I guess I will talk to you soon, buh-bye.
Boy, is it good to see you.
(R&B music)
- Jim, you're gonna
wanna sit down.
- What's going on?
- I just gotta get something off my chest,
but I know it's gonna hurt you.
It's gonna hurt me.
Your daughter, Cindy and
I, have both decided to
go our separate ways.
- Well, that sucks,
but I'm sure you'll land
right back on your feet.
- Thanks.
- So, we're on for golf
on Saturdays still?
- Oh, Jim.
I don't think we can do that.
Look, you're a great guy and all, but-
- Are you leaving me?
- This isn't easy, but I
gotta do what I gotta do.
- So, just like that?
You're out of my life?
- I'm so sorry.
You're the greatest
father-figure I've ever had.
- Who am I gonna watch The Fast
and Furious movies with now?
- Maybe your wife?
- She hates those movies.
(Tyler groans)
I was almost about to invite
you into my fantasy football league.
- Jim, stop, you're only
gonna make it worse.
- I even told all the guys
in the office about you.
I even told my boss that I
had a son that I was damn proud of.
You were always more than my
daughter's boyfriend, Tyler,
you were my best friend.
- And you were mine, but
the curtains are closing
and it's time for us
to give our final bow.
- Don't we deserve an encore?
- You always were the dreamer, Jim.
I'm gonna miss that about you.
I'm sure Cindy will go out and
find another boyfriend that
you'll end up bonding with.
You know, maybe he'll end up
liking the Discovery Channel
or window treatments, just as much as you.
- Never.
- Never say never, Jim.
Never.
(music stops)
- Tyler, you're still here?
- Cindy, hey, hey, we were um,
we were just talking about...
- Baseball.
- Baseball, yeah.
- Okay Tyler, I think
it's time for you to go.
- Okay, yeah.
(longing music)
(beat joins music)
(electronic music)
- Reach around.
(sign squeaks)